based on the data below which students
score improved the most between the
midterm and final exams and so they give
us this data in terms of a bar graph for
each student we actually have two bars
that show the midterm in blue and then
the final exam in red and they tell us
that here midterm in blue and final exam
and sometimes this is called a two
column bar graph because for each
student here you have two columns of
data so if you were actually look at the
data itself you have the midterm data
and then you have the final exam data
now they're asking us which students
score improved the most between the
midterms and the final exams so if we
look at jasmine right over here might as
well start with her since she's the most
to the left it looks like she definitely
did improve from the midterm for the
final it looks like in the midterm if I
had to guess this looks like about a I
don't know it looks like she got maybe
about a 72 or 73 on the midterm I'm just
guessing because I don't know the exact
number and it looks like on the final
she got I don't know that looks like
maybe a 77 or 78 approximately so she
improved a little bit about five points
from the midterm to the final the way
that they've given us this information
we don't know the exact numbers because
it's not it's not super precise in terms
of marking off the bars but hopefully
it'll become obvious when we look
through everyone's scores let's look at
Jeff so Jeff Jeff actually did worse
from the midterm to the final exam he
got he got looks like over an 85 on the
midterm and then on the final he got
about an 84 and 85 so he actually went
down so it's definitely not Jeff he
definitely did not improve the most he
actually went down next if you think
about Nevin it looks like Nevin actually
improved about the same much same amount
as jasmine on both scores I don't know
if Nevin is a boy or girl's name this
person on both tests this person did
better than jasmine but it looks like
the actual improvements about the same
looks like they went from about an 83 to
I don't know about an 88 I'm just
estimating it just trying to look at
look at this axis right over there and
estimating what those scores are so
Nevin and jasmine right now based on the
three we've seen are tied for the lead
now let's look at Alejandra now
Alejandra this is okay so this dumps out
she definitely improved
matically from the midterm to the final
exam it looks like on the midterm she
maybe got an 81 or an 82 so maybe this
was an 82 she got on the midterm and
then on the final looks like she got
about a 95 a 95 on the final so it's
dramatic improvement so right now
Alejandra is the leading contender for
most improved from the midterm to the
final and then finally Marta right over
here it looks like she actually got
worse from the midterm to the final she
scored in the mid-90s in the midterm and
then low 90s in the final so she's
definitely not the most improved so the
winner here is Alejandra Alejandra is
the most improved between the midterm
and the final exam